[Music]
john welcome to the show it's nice to
see you sir thanks so much for having me
tim
now
i
find your story endlessly fascinating
which means of course i have an
embarrassment of riches in terms of
materials and questions we're never
going to get through all of it
but
i
was struggling with finding a place to
begin there's so many options
but i thought i would just mention for
folks you have eight kids is that right
that's correct eight kids eight kids
your grandpa dad and brother all
truckers
if i'm not mistaken that's correct well
truck proud truckers proud trucker so
i'm just adding a little bit of color
here and there because
certainly we're going to get into many
different nooks and crannies
i thought i would just start with asking
you
to
describe what a clawback incentive is
and how you have used clawback
incentives with your kids
and incentives in general what other
incentives you have used and then we'll
we'll use that as a jumping off point
the clawback incentive is an incentive
scheme
that actually reverses
the way we think about traditional
incentives so in traditional incentives
i'm the chief economist at lyft the way
i incent my workers there
is i have them work really hard all year
and then at the end of the year
they receive a bonus if they do a good
job
that's great
now what the clawback incentive is is at
the beginning of the year
i give them the incentive
but then i tell them if they don't
perform
i will take away the incentive
and the idea behind the clawback is
i want to first of all show them the
money
and then secondly i want to invoke loss
aversion
loss aversion is something
that psychologists have taught us goes
as follows if you own something
you really really really are hurt if you
have to give it up
so the idea here is give somebody some
money
that will induce them to work harder
and when they do work harder everyone's
better off because they get to keep the
money
and my firm is better off because they
work harder
now where i've used that i've used that
in chinese manufacturing plants
i started a pre-k school
about 12 years ago
i use that with the teachers so at the
beginning of the year in september
beginning of the school year they some
of them get the bonus and then i tell
them if your kids don't perform at the
end of the school year i will take some
of it back
and lo and behold what happens they work
harder and the kids learn more
now for my own kids
i've also done the same thing any good
scientist
will use his or her own kids as subjects
so i'm no different than that
as you mentioned i have eight kids two
of those kids happen to be twins so i
have the perfect treatment and control
group
now
some things like
my oldest daughter had a very hard time
going potty on the toilet
so what do i do
i give her an incentive let's say a doll
or something else and i tell her if you
go potty on the toilet you get to keep
it
if you don't the doll is going to go and
sit in a different room and you're not
going to be able to play with the doll
that's the clawback incentive
and what were the results
the results are just remarkable
whether it's school teachers
whether it's
workers in a manufacturing plant whether
it's students
whether it's my own kids just across the
board
what happens is if you use the clawback
people work harder and everyone's better
off in the end because they're more
likely to get the reward
and you're happier because they've
worked harder so you will you're happy
to give them the incentive
so
hearing of your kids and the twins in
particular i have to imagine an
unfair share of the experimental load
lands on the twins but uh you could
disabuse me of that notion if if i'm
missing
but could you describe other ways that
you have used
incentives with your kids any any
stories or examples that come to mind
so first of all you're right that
whenever i need a really good control
that will fall on the twins but but to
be fair i have enough experiments
i think about using experimentation
to
incent inputs for example
when the kids are in third or fourth and
fifth grade i tend not to incentivize
outputs
because outputs are something that a
person has a hard time controlling
but what they can control
is the set of inputs what i mean by
inputs is how many books you read or how
many hours you spend studying those are
things that the child or the worker or
whomever
can control things like
how well you do on the exam a lot of
exams for example are graded on a curve
so you can't control how well other
students do in the classroom so it's not
really fair to give you
an incentive based on that kind of
output so so look
my incentives roll from in the classroom
to on the baseball field to on the
soccer field but it's
all the time it's using input incentives
with my kids now with my workers
whether it's at lyft or i used to be the
department chair here
at the university of chicago's econ
department there i can't really observe
inputs
so i have to reward
output and in the end it's the
organization is affected by the outputs
not the inputs
could you give an example
and don't worry folks listening i'm
going to
expand beyond the family system but i i
like to start
with something that many listeners will
identify with
and then will move in all sorts of
directions are there any specific
examples that you could give of
incentivizing and changing behavior or
molding behavior with your kids
so let's think about studying when i
think about a clawback at the beginning
of the week i will tell them if you work
intensively for an hour each night
monday night tuesday night wednesday
thursday night friday night
you can keep this incentive that i will
give you on monday morning now that
incentive can be
a pack of baseball cards for my boys
it could be
a pass to the movies
for my daughters
but the key is
give them the incentive early in the
week
and then they will perform all week for
example
an hour of studying math every night
is something that happens all the time
in my household
that at the end of the week they end up
keeping the incentive because nearly
every time they meet the goal
i have a question about the the clawback
incentive and harnessing the law
subversion and and part of why i was
looking forward to chatting with you is
that
i think it's minimizing it to say sort
of along the
lines of say freakonomics now you've had
a lot of involvement with
professor levitt and have
been featured regularly on the
freakonomics blog and elsewhere
there there are many assumptions that we
make or beliefs that we hold which
turn out not to be terribly supported by
data when you actually run experiments
and as an example when i was doing prep
for this conversation i read about
and and i might i might get the
specifics slightly off
but your examination of
matching
donations with
charitable organizations and
asking them if matching works the answer
is of course yes do you have data to
support it no not really
but looking at say
one for one matching you donate one
dollar we match a dollar or
one to two one to three and it turns out
matching does work but
the ratio is less important than just
the matching mechanism itself right it
would seem
and we can certainly explore that more
and if i screw it up please let me know
on the harnessing of loss of aversion
you know as an employer myself or as
someone who's hoping to have kids soon
i'm not going to probably not going to
catch up with you unless i adopt a lot
but i imagine in my mind that
workers will respond well when they are
given a bonus at the end of their
performance review period whatever that
is but that
over time maybe in the long term and not
in the short term if people are given
something that is taken away that that
might breed resentment
or
some type of learned helplessness where
they'll just
not
attempt to put forth their best effort
is that
grounded in any of the data in any way
or
are there any
side effects you know that's a great
question when you think about
using behavioral nudges
or you think about using
behavioral incentives
one
very important issue that you always
need to recognize and keep in mind is
will it keep working over and over and
over again
and then secondly
does it have any side effects
so in the case of the clawback you could
imagine that you run it one time
and it works and then when you try it a
second and a third time it depreciates
it really doesn't work that well
or you could imagine
that
you hire a bunch of school teachers like
i did down in chicago heights and give
them the claw back and within three
months they all quit because they hate
it it's just too stressful and it's too
burdensome on them now those are two
very important considerations for any
incentive that we talk about what we
found so far
is in terms of the depreciation
it does depreciate a little bit like
most behavioral nudges but not a ton
so so on that side you don't have to
keep creating a new mouse trap that the
the real mouse trap in the first one the
clawback works reasonably well
and it has over time for a long time
now
the side effect one is also sort of
interesting because what you find
is that
many workers actually like the clawback
because they view it as a commitment
device
and what i mean by that is
you know most things in life
you have to
exert effort today
and you receive benefits in the future
so think about climate change think
about your own health you don't really
want to go to the doctor you don't
really want to go to the dentist because
it's a cost now and the benefits are in
the future think about why people drop
out of school
you know as a 16 year old there's a lot
of cost now and the benefits aren't for
a long time is humans
we do a really bad job at those types of
issues and that's why we have problems
like climate change and you don't take
care of your health and too many people
drop out
what's nice about the clawback
is it takes that problem and turns it
around
because it takes the benefits from the
end and brings them to the beginning so
you get the good stuff right away
and that serves as a commitment device
for many people so some people in our
experiments will actually pay real money
to have the claw back to get to use the
claw back in the end there are some of
course that hate it
but there are enough that love it that
on that dimension it actually turns out
to be a doubly good incentive because
you not only are better as the owner but
the workers like it more too
question about the chinese manufacturing
is speaking to the durability of the
incentive yeah
and again i'm getting probably the
specifics off and you can correct me but
it seemed that it it it worked on the
order of
something like six months not on the
order of weeks
at least in the example that i read and
maybe maybe that was just the sampling
interval so maybe it lasted for years
for all i know but my question is what
was the reward period does that make
sense makes perfect sense so what we did
in the chinese manufacturing plant is
we had weekly reward periods so every
monday morning
they were given the bonus
and then that cleared on friday
afternoon
so our experiment lasted six months
where we would move people in and out of
clawback incentives we'd put some people
in the standard incentive the standard
incentive of course is work all week and
at the end of the week you get your
bonus
and we were always comparing whether the
clawback does better than the standard
and could you speak to
inputs versus outputs and what your
metrics were yeah absolutely so in that
example all of our metrics were outputs
so the output in china was the number of
non-defective
items that came off the manufacturing
belt
and each team had a goal
and that goal was if it was met you got
to keep your bonus if the goal wasn't
met you had to give back your bonus
so in the manufacturing plant as in
many of our experiments that involve
workers we are looking at outputs now
when i talk about my kids i want to
incentivize an input but it's really
hard to do that in the workplace
yeah that makes sense that makes a lot
of sense
i mentioned donations earlier
and
i'd love to segue to
tipping
and i know you've
spent more time than most
looking at tipping yeah yeah do you want
me to tell you the vignette about
donations and then how i can pivot that
into tipping that's perfect i would love
that my research agenda in charitable
giving
actually started back in the late 90s
and a lot of people ask me
why did you get involved in working on
the science of charitable giving
and
a lot of times they assume it's because
of my altruism
and i tell them that's not the case
what happened was i was an assistant
professor at the university of central
florida in 1998
an assistant professor means you're the
lowest on the on the poll right right
nobody gives a damn about you you know
you're just trying to do the best you
can so i'm sitting in orlando florida in
my office minding my own business
and i hear a knock on the door
i open my office door and there's the
dean
of the college of business standing in
my doorway
so
i say dean uh his name was thomas keon
uh dean tom how can i help you he says
john
i want to start a center for
environmental policy analysis
and i want you to help me start that
center
and your first job is going to be to
raise money
so i'm thinking well
what i've never raised any money before
i'm a truck driver son what what's going
on here
so
he said think about it
and come back to me
so i thought about it for a few days and
i went to the dean's office and i told
him
this is a great opportunity
and i will do it
if you satisfy two conditions
one condition is
i want to run the fundraiser
as a field experiment
because i want to learn about why people
give
what keeps them committed to the cause
and two
i need some upfront money
and that's what i kind of learned in
those two days is i went out and talked
to a bunch of fundraising specialists
and they told me
the key is to have upfront money
so the dean gave me five thousand
dollars
big whoop right
but importantly he gave me a big list of
potential donors
who i could ask to give money to
the center for environmental policy
analysis okay now i'm in business
my my research agenda has always been
to use the world as my lab
and if you're ever trying to accomplish
something
do it scientifically
so you can not only figure out what
works and why but then you can get it
right the next time so
i did this fundraiser
and what i first learned was
i talked to dozens
of fundraising gurus
practitioners
strategists etc etc etc and they all had
rules of thumb
they all said things like
use a three to one match rather than a
one to one match because a three to one
match will raise more money when i say
three to one i mean for every hundred
dollars somebody gives
the charity matches it with three
hundred dollars that's a three to one
match versus a one to one you know all
these
all these great anecdotes and each time
i would ask them
can you give me the data
behind
these gut feelings
no i can't
i said well how do you know they're true
and every person said well
that's just how we always do it that's
how my boss did it
now i'm thinking holy cow this is two to
three percent of the gdp of our nation
is charitable giving right two or three
percent of wallet is giving of money
forget about the time you know add add
volunteerism to that and you might get
seven percent of gdp so it's a very
important sector
but when i learned
that it's mostly built on anecdotes i
said
man we're in business
because now i can use this as a is a
research agenda
to explore generosity
and i can help charities
use science
to raise more money so i've been at that
for now close to 25 years
partnering with charities helping them
raise more money helping them leverage
science
and you end up learning some really
interesting facts about people
for like for example
when you look at what drives a man to
give versus a woman
a man is driven a lot by the tax
advantages
that charitable giving gives you that's
called the price effect
in giving whereas
women are driven more
by altruism and social pressure
so now these become two sort of
important features that
you might say well that affects
charitable giving
and that's about generosity
but what about other parts of society
like tipping
is can can we take what we learn
about the generosity to
you know the sierra club or the united
way or what have you
and apply those elements to
what happens in the world of
tipping somebody whether it's an uber
driver
or tipping a waiter or what have you
and it's sort of interesting because
sometimes you can
and sometimes you can't
like one example is when you look at
the charitable giving data
so i have the irs data so i have
everyone's tax form from like
2008
to
2017.
so i can explore
all kinds of different cuts of those
data
and i can tell you
that as it turns out at each income
percentile so if you say the average
income earner in the united states is
like 58 000
if you look at all people who make that
amount of money
women give a lot more than men in that
income bucket
so you look across all of the income
buckets and a fact is
is that women in every income bucket
give more than men
to charitable causes
so now you'd say okay
that must be also true in tipping
it's not
in fact it's just the opposite in
tipping so you can say well where's john
getting his tipping data from
i was a chief economist at uber
back in 2017
and tk travis kalanick came to me and
said john you need to help us
keep the drivers in uber because there's
this crazy delete uber campaign hashtag
the lead uber campaign
that's killing us on the both the driver
and the rider side
and my solution back then was let's roll
out tipping on the app
so we rolled out tipping on the app my
team at uber was called ubernomics
so team ubernomics helped roll out
tipping
and what we find there is across the
board
men tip a lot more than women
so there's sort of this interesting
dynamic that
in charitable giving
where you do it face to face
or you do it to be recognized women are
given a lot more than men but remember
on the uber app
what happens is you do it anonymously
and you don't do it face to face and in
that case men actually give more than
women in tips
what are some of the
learnings
around increasing frequency or amount of
tipping
from your your many experiments there
are sort of some interesting facts about
what happens
in that uber car
okay so a first fact is
that if your listeners want to join the
one percent
a lot of times people say i want to be
in the one percent
now in this case
only one percent
of writers
tip every trip
that kind of blew my mind that's wild i
never would have guessed that yeah
because in that charitable giving game
like nine out of ten people give to a
charitable cause at least once every
year
but when you think about
the uber experience only one percent
of people tip every time
and interestingly
roughly
60
never tip
wow
now in the middle of course are the
sometimes tippers
so we did this big
data just
big data grab from our experiment so now
we're talking about 23 million
observations a big data set
and we can look at a lot of averages and
what you find are things
like men tip female drivers more than
they tip male drivers
that's a fact especially when
the female drivers are younger
so what happens is the older female
drivers say 60 years old and beyond
those female drivers are tipped the same
as the male drivers in that age group
but the big difference is with the 21 to
25 year old drivers where females earn
about six percent more
in tips than the males do
and that it's all driven by male riders
which is sort of an interesting fact
now i'm gonna let your imagination
uh tim go with that about why that
happens i don't want to go into that
here i'll let your imagination go i
don't have to imagine very long
continue
please
but are all these kinds of facts like
this you know the average trip only
about 15
of trips are tipped
and
conditional on tipping the average tip
is about 10 12
of the fare
so you do have things like a bigger bill
is is a bigger tip that's what we have
in restaurants too where people tip 20
percent
but the big thing about tipping is
people tip a lot more
if it's face to face
versus when
it's anonymous so the way we did tipping
at uber
was you don't get asked to tip
until after the ride is done and you're
removed in space and time from the
driver
and we did that on purpose because tk
said john
i don't want tipping to be a tax
on riders i want it to be something that
is truly done for exceptional service
we want to separate it in space and time
and then that's what we got is you know
roughly 15 percent of trips are tipped
now if if i think to my restaurant
experience so i grew up working in
restaurants and
the
the checks have changed over time if
we're talking about computer generated
bills slash checks and one of the
changes i don't know when this started
and i don't know if it's supported by
data i would hope so
it certainly affects has affected how i
tip
but it
has been
check boxes where it'll have rather than
making you do the math it will say
15 20 25 there's a check box and there's
the amount and then there's the total
and
that raises the question for me of what
types of user interface or flow
experiments
worked well if you're able to speak to
it and i think you are because i did i
remember reading about
you getting a call from jeff bezos and
one of your conditions for possibly
engaging with amazon being
the ability to publish your findings
that's right and uh just to give a
snapshot of that you didn't take the job
because there were going to be trade
secrets they wouldn't be publishable
however you helped introduce someone who
was hired and i think still works there
and he sends you a what is it a
christmas card every year
with his net worth at the bottom
something like that which is outstanding
i hope he sends you some chocolates too
he better send me a bag of cash the way
amazon's been doing they gave me that
offer the stock was seven dollars a
share oh oh
so so tk was open as i understand it to
you publishing yeah
so could you could you share some of the
maybe design experiments or changes or
tweaks that turned out to be effective
it doesn't have to be uber specific but
it certainly could be
early on
amazon jeff bezos came to me and asked
me to be their chief economist and
oh boy oh boy oh boy whenever i go back
and look at that contract
it was a contract that was heavily laden
with
options
and
ah
tim tim tim so if i could go back i i
still think i i can honestly say this i
i would do the same thing today i i did
give up millions of dollars no doubt
about that
but in the end i'm a scientist and
i've always thought that my calling
was that
to use the world as your lab
is a great opportunity
to make the world a better place
and i really felt i could help amazon i
really did
but
in the end
they just couldn't get over the hurdle
of
i needed to publish
in academic journals
as a scientist because i not only wanted
to solve amazon.com's problems i want to
solve the world's problems and and i i
certainly get it
that their basic premise was look we
want you to come in and help us make a
ton of money and at the time he was
talking about something called the cloud
which i didn't even know what that was
in fact he goes john the two next big
things are going to be the cloud and the
economics team and you're going to be
the guy who hires all the economists and
he says let me tell you about this cloud
thing i was like he goes you're going to
help me price the cloud like i don't
even know what that is and i just
pretended i did but
like honestly didn't know anything about
it okay so tk calls uber calls
and
uber says
we understand what happened at
amazon.com because of jeff holden
jeff holden
was at amazon.com back then and then he
ended up leaving for groupon
he was at groupon for a while and then
he went to uber
and when tk wanted a chief economist he
ended up talking to his exec team jeff
holden's one of them
and jeff said you know there's this guy
who we really liked at amazon
and he wouldn't come because of this
restriction or constraint that he said
he's an academic and he wants to publish
some of the work
and tk said well if he's good
let's bring him in
and he can publish some of his work
into his credit
tk stayed true
to that promise
so
not only around tipping we have two
academic papers about
the economics of tipping questions like
how should you do the presets you know
at the bottom of your app you say you
have
zero one dollar or two dollars or should
it be one two and four or should it be
zero percent five percent twenty percent
we have all those configurations and
kind of the bottom line is you want that
you want there to be a choice you don't
wanna have people fill in the number
you you want there to be a box that you
can check but make sure the boxes aren't
too high
because if they're too high you're going
to get a zero
too high in a dollar amount too high of
like 50 100 150
or
25
45 70
a lot of times people say those are out
of my range so i'm gonna do zero
so you don't want to do too high
you don't want to do too low because
then you might be leaving money on the
table for the driver
so it becomes an art and it's an art
that you can only figure out
with field experiments
and
a lot of those you know five percent ten
percent twenty percent
those are individual specific
so
that doesn't fit
with
just everyone sometimes the low it means
high for somebody else or a really high
set of presets is low for somebody else
so just like the price and
in the various other pieces of the
algorithm an optimal tipping scheme
will take account of the consumers
traits and how they've tipped in the
past okay
so another line of research that we
worked on
at uber was what i call the economics of
apologies
and as you know
it was pretty rocky at uh at uber when i
was there in fact i think there's a
there's a new show coming out right
called like super pumped or something
yep so not only was i
one of the earliest advisors to uber
starting in 2009 2010 so i i was along
for that ride and watching things very
very closely
pun intended but i actually also
am friends with the
i believe he's i don't know if he'd be
considered the creator but he's
certainly producing and writing
brian koppelman and david levine
super pumped or adapting it for screen
i'm not involved with that at all but he
uh he's a good guy so yes based on the
book so there's never a dull moment in
ride sharing
yeah can you tell them that when the
thing comes out that i want matt damon
to play the chief economist
is that too much to ask tim well you
know what they have worked with matt
damon before so i will put in the
request all right
all right
so so let me tell you the story quickly
about apologies is that okay tim do you
want to hear that yes please
this is kind of a perfect example of
i think the leadership of uber and and
how they were open to science
so
i'm scheduled to give a keynote talk
at our big annual meetings
they're called the american economic
association meetings so
these are annual meetings that take
place every january
okay great so i'm on the schedule to
give a keynote talk
alongside a guy who ends up winning the
nobel prize in development economics
named angus deaton
he's there to criticize field
experiments and i'm there to be
the the supporter of field experiments
so i get picked up
at my house here in hyde park chicago
because the meetings are downtown
chicago just happened to get lucky that
year the meetings rotate to a different
big city every year okay
so the uber car picks me up
and
as usual i'm still working on my slides
but but i i look at my watch and it's
noon roughly noon and i'm supposed to be
on stage at 12 30.
so
the driver starts taking me down there
and we get about three quarters of the
way down i look up
look at my watch
and i'm like this is perfect i i have to
just finish this last slide i'm gonna
walk in these slides are going to be
great
next time i look up
i'm in the front of my house back in
hiding oh
no
oh no
and i'm like
no what the blank is going on here
and the driver said well the app blinked
and professor you were so busy working i
didn't want to disturb you
i thought that you changed the
destination because you forgot something
at home
i said no take me back
down to
to the conference so okay so i get there
i run in everything turns out fine
but
that evening when i got home
i ended up walking out to our garage
that's uh separated from my home and my
wife always knows when i go out to the
garage it means somebody's gonna have
hell to be paid
i call tk
and
i say hey tk
let me tell you about what i think of
your blankety blank app
and guess what tk i will never take an
uber again
i am just going to simply take a lyft i
said tk you can call your chief
economist a lift loyalist oh wow he must
love that
so
so i said you know what tk
the worst part
about the story is that i never received
an apology
and he says well john
we haven't gotten to that yet
and i said we have now
so what my team did is we explored
in
big big data sets
how much business does uber lose
from bad trips
now here you don't want to do an
experiment because i don't want to just
give people bad trips on purpose
what i have to do
is i need to find for example tim
and then i need to find
tim's statistical twin in the data
and i need to find when tim gets a bad
trip
but at the exact same time and over the
same route when his statistical twin
gets a good trip
and then i can look at in the future
say for the next 90 days
does tim who got a bad trip
spend less money than tim's statistical
twin
what happens is you do
in fact millions and millions and
millions of lost revenue
happened because of bad trips
okay so now i showed that
bad trips cost uber
hundreds of millions of dollars now what
are you gonna do about it that's where
the science comes in
so we ended up developing a scheme
where we
did various apologies within an hour of
when a person had a bad trip it's like
one apology could be
simply a basic apology and an email tim
we're sorry about your bad trip we know
we should be doing better
please accept our apology
that's one treatment but another
treatment is the exact same apology
with a five dollar coupon
that please take this five dollar coupon
for your next trip
what we find is we can undo a lot of the
bad stuff of the bad trips
but nearly every time you need that cash
coupon
words just don't matter but a little bit
of cash with the with the apology ends
up undoing about a third of the bad
stuff so now we're talking tens of
millions of dollars and true to his word
tk could have said look
that's a great trade secret we don't
want anyone else including lyft to know
about that but tk let us write that up
as a scientific paper
and now it's in an academic journal and
we can all learn from it about the
economics of apologies i have to give
tk credit because you think about the
and you obviously but
as
the fierce competitor he is
it's all the more impressive to me that
he would
allow that and you think of the
potential
ripple effects of that not just within
ride sharing but outside of ride sharing
i mean it it it hopefully translates to
a better
customer experience in different sectors
right absolutely that's part of the
potential consequence of being able to
publish you're right and i think that tk
really got and logan green does too and
john zimmer now at at left you know we
have great papers coming out of there
too but they they totally get that we're
not only here
to change the face of transportation
but we also have another gem
called big data
and a lot of information that we can use
and we can leverage
to help some of societal's problems
be attenuated and and that's the great
thing i think about
firms and corporations and organizations
today when they're willing to do that
even though it's not in their financial
best interest to do so it's an
incredible opportunity i remember way
back in the day they ended up i think
cutting this short but
when uh you know there there existed the
god view and the ability to look at all
this all this data and you you could
really learn a lot about human nature
and they would publish on the on the
uber blog and elsewhere
all sorts of correlations that were
endlessly fascinating but it's it's
really when you have a big enough
data set and you're dealing with
individuals and you're able to identify
not only their behaviors but how their
behaviors change with different
incentives and uis and so on
i mean you're really
just looking at this gigantic petri dish
called
humanity and human nature right at the
end of the day absolutely absolutely
you're spot on and let me ask you if i
can find this quickly enough
looking through my many notes here
what you have learned about uh if that's
the right way to phrase it human nature
and i want to bring up
car dealerships
so i believe and please correct me i'm
getting this wrong but
the behavioralist meets the market
measuring social preferences and
reputation effects in actual
transactions this is in the journal
political economy 2006
but the quote
that i that i really liked and this
tells you i'm kind of a hobby at heart i
guess
quote very few people will not screw
each other list says there are very few
nice people out there could you just
elaborate on that and kind of flesh out
how that came about
so the paper you bring up is actually
near and dear to my heart because
you know one reason why i got
involved in economics to start was
you know back in the day in the late 80s
i was a baseball card dealer
so what that meant was i went to these
large conventions
to buy sell and trade things like hank
aaron
barry bonds or ken griffey jr whatever
baseball cards
and
what i what i noticed was everything
that was happening in that convention
was not always in accord
with economic theory
and i thought that what i was learning
in the classroom
could actually be tested
at these baseball card conventions
so i started to do it in the early 90s
that's that's one of the very early
work in economics that uses the world as
the lab
and it's exploring
things like
why do people trade why don't people
trade why do people negotiate the way
they do
why do dealers give women higher price
offers than men cedric cedric said you
know discrimination gender pay gap et
cetera et cetera
so
along comes the early 2000s and
what i notice in economics is that there
is an explosion
of research on something called
social preferences
and what that means is
we want to measure
how much people care for other people
okay so
clearly they do clearly giving to
charitable causes is two and a half
percent of gdp in america so clearly
people are giving to others
but the types of estimates that these
studies were showing is that you know
you'll give up half of your wealth to
some anonymous stranger and i started to
wonder
how far can you push these lab results
if you go to a market
where people are buying selling and
trading
for their livelihood so what i did was i
set up an experiment
where everyone in the experiment knew
that they were taking part in an
experiment
guess what happened they all were really
nice
and and they all were exactly like the
literature in economics said they should
be they're all
homo be nice to everyone rather than
homo economicus right so
then what i did is i observed those same
people
in the marketplace when they didn't know
they were being observed
doing the exact same thing
that i had them do in the experiment
guess what they do now
totally screw the other guy over
and they're about maximizing their own
incomes so what happened to all this
generosity and all all of this social
preference i'm being nice to other
people
the market and the competition and the
anonymity that i'm doing this and if
nobody can detect me
i'm going to actually do it so then i
added a twist to that paper what i did
is i had them act
in the marketplace and they did not know
that they're part of an experiment but
now what they sell
can be graded
by a professional certifier in there you
find that they start to be nice again so
what's happening is that they care about
their reputations
and whenever you can check them on their
reputation
they're nice why because they care about
the long run and they want repeat
business but when you can't check them
on their their reputation or you can't
check the quality of the goods they sell
they outright screw people over
you know this is uh
makes me think about
one of my
sensitive spots with respect to
uber and ride sharing in general which
was
how
and i'm not sure
of the right kind of bias
label to apply to this but you would see
in the news you know uber driver this
uber driver that all assorted bad
behavior which statistically was a very
very small percentage
but it the implication was
that somehow in the early days
especially that ride sharing was more
dangerous or
lower quality than taxi rides but the
fact of the matter was there was no data
capture with taxi rides there was no
accountability no rating no nothing
and
the the costs and the
events the adverse events were largely
invisible right so that's right it's
just a very unfair
comparison
well let's let's hop from car
dealerships
going to a place that is is much more
meta because i i
admire
your ability and anyone's ability to
test assumptions
even if they lead you to some some very
unexpected surprising or even
uncomfortable
conclusions and i have
as you can see and people are on video
piles and piles of paper in front of me
you are a scholar well i pretended i
play one on the internet
and uh let me let me read a line
from you and i would love for you to
explain what it means here we go
just a few sentences a first step to
rise up my critical thinking hierarchy
is to practice theory of mind people
have a really hard time doing this but
once you do you avoid all kinds of silly
mistakes at home in the workplace and on
the streets
so there are
kind of two terms
that i would love for you to define and
then you can expand in any way that
makes sense critical thinking hierarchy
and then
theory of mind practicing theory of mind
critical thinking is a bit like
creativity
right you know it when you see it it's
very hard to define what critical
thinking
means
now in my work i've written a recent
academic paper on critical thinking i
view it sort of in two camps
one camp is
how you use data
and how you gather data
to make logical decisions
a lot of times people make fundamental
errors
when generating data for example
if i really think uber is a great idea
early on
every data point that i get back that
says it's a bad idea i put on the
sidelines right and every data point
that comes to me that it's a great idea
i say that data is right that's called
confirmation bias
and it's one of the most important
impediments to figuring out if your idea
is good or not okay so
we have biases in how we generate
accumulate and interpret data that's one
kind of critical thinking
the other kind of critical thinking is
more abstract
and this is where theory of mind comes
in so theory of mind means
how well do you put yourself in the
shoes of another person
so
there's a theory in economics called
game theory
and game theory was
started by a
really old mathematician who's now
unfortunately dead named john nash john
nash john nash said that's the name of
my dog the bar scene in a beautiful mind
exactly one of my favorite movies
beautiful mind even though the bar scene
got it wrong oh really yeah they messed
up the nash equilibrium the reason why
is because at least one of them should
have gone for the blonde
so in equilibrium is given everyone
else's choices
would i change my choice
and if you wouldn't change your choice
that's an equilibrium
if you would change your choice then
that's not an equilibrium remember what
happened in the bar scene they all went
for the brunettes
even though they all wanted the blonde
so that was like a definition of not an
equilibrium but anyway
we'll cut ron howard a break yeah
don't don't let facts get in the way of
a good story now
how could you write that bar scene at
the palmer house okay so
now theory of mind ends up being super
important for the abstract part of
critical thinking because
your next move
needs to be in part determined by how
you think
that person will react
and if you can put yourself in the shoes
whether it's do i do i lower my price on
uber and how would lyft respond or
should i spend more money in ads if i'm
united airlines how will southwest
respond etc etc etc all of these kinds
of examples now theory of mind is
how well do you put yourself in the
shoes
of another person and figure out then
what your optimal action should be now
you see tim when you start having kids
you're gonna have to use theory of mind
to say okay how am i gonna get my kid to
pay attention on the soccer field or how
am i gonna get my kid to pay attention
in second grade math if they're really
not interested at all because they're
doing math at a seventh grade level
and that's you need to put yourself in
the shoes of whether it's your student
your worker
your collaborator your adversary
whomever
and you need to then backward induct
and act in an optimal way that that's
theory of mind
i have uh not surprisingly many
questions about this so
the next question that leaps to mind for
me is like
let's assuming that theory of mind
is uh or understanding and practicing
theory of mind is a valuable skill
with tangible benefits
how do you develop it right and i i
suppose if we wanted to speak broadly a
lot of folks would say well it sounds
like you're practicing empathy but then
on on the on perhaps the other side of
the spectrum on the more concrete side
of things i would say well
if i just gave you a thousand bucks and
made you play online poker
and set a max
amount that you could lose per game to
ensure a certain number of repetitions
you would probably get better at
predicting how others or at least get
better at attempting to predict how
others will respond giving certain
gambits and strategies and so on
how would you suggest
people develop this skill or are there
different approaches that you might
suggest people take or books or
resources anything for people who want
to get better at this so what i would
tell the listener is to start with what
an economist calls
the primitives
of decision making and what i mean by
that is try to figure out
what are the preferences
of that other person what are the
beliefs of the other person and what are
the constraints
of the other person because all choice
will be governed
by these three primitives so for example
if i know that
somebody adheres to the social norm
of never ever tipping
then if i'm trying to do something to
give them get them to tip if i put
myself in their shoes regardless of what
i do they're never going to tip so i
should not spend a lot of money
trying to convince them or induce them
to tip
because what is governing their tipping
behavior is the strong social norm that
they will never tip
so that's called a constraint in a
person's world so i think the first step
is to try to figure out
what are the primitives
of the person's decision making and
after you figure that out you then say
well what's my optimal action given
that the person operates in this way you
know a lot of times would be how much
money do they have do they have the
mental capacity to actually solve the
problem that i'm giving them
when i play poker
you know i i think
poker is a hard game because it's really
hard to randomize
so if you're playing against really good
players
you need to first of all decide
what what is the fraction of times that
you're going to randomize and then you
need to do it
you know when i say randomize i mean
what fraction of hands are you going to
bluff
and then if you say it's let's say
10 of the time
you then need to figure out which 10 of
the time
now humans are terrible at that
humans are terrible at doing something
in a random way so what i do when i play
poker i use the seconds hand in a clock
to say well if i'm gonna bluff
say 10 of the time
then i look at the second hand and say
if it's at a certain point in the clock
i'll bluff
and if it's not i won't
and then that helps me because it's an
exogenous machine
that is not susceptible to my own biases
because when you ask somebody to
for example create a random sequence of
coin flips you you can ask a really
smart person
to say create 10 coin flips in a row
and what they'll do is they'll say heads
heads tails
tails heads
what they'll have nearly exactly five
heads and five tails over the 10
and they won't have enough runs because
sometimes you have telltale tail tail
but when a human mind creates it they
don't do enough runs and they do too
close to 50 50. that's just how we're
built so you need an exogenous force to
help you with things like that in poker
anything else
do you play poker often have you played
for a long time
during the rage i played and
the explosion yeah the world series of
poker on television
series was starting phil hellmuth was on
ivy these guys
and
i ended up flying to australia
to give a keynote in um a place called
alice springs
it's way out in the in the boondocks of
australia i don't know if you've ever
been there but i've never been to alice
springs i've been to uh i've been to
australia don't recognize alice springs
yeah so i'm out there and um
there's a casino there
and it so happens that the conference
is at the casino
so is the keynote speaker on i think it
was a friday night
they were going to take me out to dinner
wine and dine me that's typically what
you do with the keynote speaker
so around 1 o'clock that afternoon i
said well the dinner doesn't start till
eight i'm gonna join this poker
tournament
and you know thinking i'm gonna be out i
won't make the next table etc
it turns out that i get on this
magnificent run
and i make the final table and by this
time it's eight o'clock so the
conference organizers are standing
around
saying come on john we have to go
i end up making the final two it was an
aussie woman in me
and i ended up
it was kind of an out of body experience
but i won the bracelet wow and and it
wasn't that i was very good but i did a
little theory of mind i i'm sure i got
lucky a few times on the flop
maybe on the river got lucky once or
twice
but
i ended up kind of retiring there but
i'm a little bit like michael jordan
let's retire on top so i got my
australian bracelet
and i haven't really played that much
since i just don't have time to play
but it's an interesting game that i
think people undervalue skill
because i think poker is a lot more
skill obviously there's a ton of luck i
get that but there's a lot more skill
than people realize it's it's it's
really a great especially if you have a
long time series yeah of tournaments
that the best end up winning and i and i
certainly wasn't the best so i i uh i
kind of retired after that bracelet i am
fascinated by poker and i've actually
interviewed phil on the on the podcast
he's hilarious i bet he's hilarious very
smart very aggressive guy and
i
recall also really enjoying i recognize
this as blackjack and specifically i
think it was single deck
or maybe two deck blackjack
in bringing down the house which was
later made into 21.
let's hop to
scaling so the new book is the voltage
effect how to make good ideas great and
great ideas
scale
why
write
this book
you have many options
with how to spend your time you have
many different projects i don't know how
on earth you honestly have your hands in
so many things
we haven't covered five percent of it
why why write this book
it's a good question about you know we
should always always always
evaluate how we want to spend our time
because opportunity cost of time is very
expensive
i was growing tired
on the one hand
when i go and give lectures
a lot of the
audience especially the younger audience
will
ask me a question
along the lines of
you know we've been fighting poverty
for decades we've been doing study after
study after study
to fight poverty
how come we're not making a dent in it
and you can substitute poverty out for
discrimination
public education what have you
and we haven't really made a deep impact
even though scientists have been working
on this for a long time
now
that coupled with an experience that i
had
in chicago heights so in chicago heights
i started a preschool from scratch
with my friends roland fryer and steve
levitt steve levitz freakonomics author
roland fryer's famous economist at
harvard
we we start a preschool for three four
and five year olds and it took a lot of
shoe leather
and we end up running this for four
years and i'm on the ground day to day
today running it and i get great results
and then i go to scale it and i talk to
policy makers
and they tell me
john that's a great little study
but it's not going to scale
and i ask them
why and they say
it doesn't have the silver bullet
and i say
what do you mean silver bullet what what
does that exactly mean i've been doing
social science research for 25 years
and i've never heard this argument that
my idea won't scale because it doesn't
have the silver bullet
and then they say well we just don't
know about this
but
every time an expert tells us they have
a great idea
it always fails to scale
okay so then the the third part of this
trifecta
was
my wife and i are sitting down the
street from the uber headquarters on
market street we're sitting in a cafe
and i'm telling my wife about the
chicago heights project and how it's so
frustrating i'm telling her about all
these people who always ask me why
aren't we making a dent in poverty or
discrimination and then i'm telling her
about scaling at uber and she says you
know what
for the next part in your career
you should take on scaling
and i said what the heck
let's do it
i said let's do it and because
all of these threads in my life the
white house
the creating the early childhood program
working at uber and now lyft all of
these had features
of scaling and then when you come to the
realization that you only make
big change at scale
you start to say
why don't we have science around scaling
why is it the case that people write a
book
that say something like move fast and
break things or throw spaghetti at the
wall
and if it sticks
good or fake it till you make it you
know you say
where's the science behind that and
there isn't any so
my chore back then when i first started
saying i'm going to take scaling
seriously
is
basically i want to do the science of
using science
and i've i've created science in the
past but we haven't created it in a way
that is meant to scale
what we do is we say i want to do a
great idea in the petri dish
and then after i'm done with it i move
on to the next idea
i don't take seriously from the
beginning that if i want to change the
world somebody's going to have to scale
this
and i need to understand the features
that are important when scaling in the
petri dish itself
so all of that came together and i said
look we're going to change the world by
understanding the science of using
science
i want to first just give voice to an
observation and that is
thinking back to your story of the
the onstage debate
the pro field studies camp
represented by you and then the i
suppose the
criticisms of field studies on the
opposite side
it strikes me that one of the enormous
benefits of field studies
and again i don't know what i'm talking
about so please correct me if i'm wrong
is that you can in some respects get
around the replicability crisis that is
found in basically every nook and cranny
of science because
you don't have to
write grants or raise funding for a tiny
pilot study that will never be
replicated if you're working with an
uber
you have incentives aligned you have
incredible kind of longitudinal data and
you have millions of data points
i don't know i i just wanted to sort of
lob that out there no tim you're right
when you think about the
credibility crisis or the replication
crisis in science
it really goes along the lines of
you had a camp of people do lab
experiments in a lab experiment is you
bring a group of sophomores into a
classroom
and you have them do a task that they
typically don't do
right and that's the the experimental
approach in psychology
and it was the experimental approach
before before i came into economics it
was largely
do things in the lab and
what was difficult there
is that if you wanted to generalize
those results to the extra lab world
a lot of the features of the extra lab
world that might matter in decision
making
are set at different points of the dial
in the lab so like the first obvious
thing is
the world is not filled by by rich white
kids who are in the lab doing the
experiments at the fancy universities
right right the world is filled with
truck drivers
and all kinds of other people so that's
where it starts but it doesn't end there
because remember
anonymity
or whether somebody's watching you or
whether you have experience in doing
something or
whether people opt in or out of a market
right people in a market tend to be the
winners the ones who you don't observe
may have tried and they're gone they're
long gone yeah so there's selection into
markets too so in the field you have
not only the right people but you also
have the right set of circumstances
and what you're getting to is right
that when you can partner with a
government i work a lot with governments
i work a lot with firms but when you can
get big data quickly at scale
you can in a very fast way
find out you know did that result in
seattle on green cars you know a bunch
of people in seattle love green cars if
you're if you're a lift consumer but
they really don't like it that much in
akron right so it's you can quickly find
these things out and then you scale
where you should scale
and you try something new where you
shouldn't be scaling
and i think that
organizations whether they're for-profit
or non-profit or governmental
these are unique opportunities that
we're just scratching the surface
and one of the external benefits what
economists call an ex a positive
externality
is that it's going to be a lot easier to
replicate and the firm
has a really strong incentive to
replicate because they don't want to
waste a bunch of money
yeah absolutely
so let's let's come back to
this mention of the silver bullet so
yeah i've read that you have said
scaling is not a silver bullet problem
rather it is an anna karenina problem
could you explain what you mean by that
and then
at some point we don't have to do it
right now but i would love for you to
kind of map out a success case and then
a
failure case or a semi-failure case
and sort of uh
do an autopsy on on both if that makes
any sense but let's let's begin with not
a silver bullet problem
scaling is rather an anna karenina
problem what on earth does that mean
the typical policy maker
argues two things
one
that the result in the petri dish
won't scale and what they really mean by
that is that there will be a voltage
effect
so what i mean by voltage effect is
you have a great result in the petri
dish
but when you scale it up you turn that
mountain into a molehill
okay so
great result in the original research
scale it up you get nothing
that's the voltage effect okay
now policymakers will say
that
truly scalable ideas
need to have the silver bullet
now
they're exactly wrong there what i found
in my research and what i talk about in
the book
is that the silver bullet is really like
if you have this one great
characteristic you can scale it's like a
best shot technology
it's scaling is actually a weakest link
problem
and what i mean by weakest link
is so go back to tolstoy
tolstoy starts anna karenina
but which one of the best first lines
ever in a novel
happy families are all alike
each unhappy family is unhappy in its
own way
scaling is identical to that the way i
think about scaling
is scalable ideas are all alike
each unscalable idea is unscalable in
its own way so now you can say well what
do you mean and what i found is that
there are five major reasons
why
ideas don't scale
and that's what i call the five vital
signs in the book
so your idea is scalable if it doesn't
have one of these flaws
you see so it's a weakest link when i
say weakest link think about airport
security
the airplane is only as secure
as the weakest link
think about your automobile
the automobile will work
but it breaks if you have a flat tire or
if a piston isn't firing that's a
weakest link problem
because it only works as long as each of
the features is at a certain level
that's how i want you to think about the
anna k problem
okay
so
now once you determine
does your idea have these five vital
signs let's go through an example to
help bring these vital signs to life yes
please
one of my favorite scientists jonas sulk
so
sulk
is responsible for the polio vaccination
what sulk does is he first does like a
lot of great scientists do
he tries it out on his own kids
he finds
it works skin in the game
you got a lot of skin in the game
and then he finds that he can replicate
that result
so those original results
were not a false positive
that's vital sign number one
does your idea have voltage
so sulk found that it does it's not a
false positive his initial result
now what jonas sulk does
is he tries it out on a lot of different
kids
what he finds
is it works for every kid
so now he knows that the audience what i
call know your audience or know your
slice of the pie he finds wow it works
for all kids that's vital sign number
two
understand how big of a piece of the pie
you have or know your audience and be be
true to yourself about measuring how big
can this market be okay
now here is where sulk
enters
sort of a thin ice
and that's
understand the situation
in which your idea can work
so
think about covid
covet vaccinations have worked but it's
really hard to get the shot in people's
arms
so like a lot of medications medication
adherence matters
and getting people to take the
vaccination matters a lot medicine's
good according to science
now how do you get it in people's arms
that's where
this covid vaccination scheme that we're
up to right now has failed it hasn't
been able to deliver
this is where sulk is brilliant because
what sulk does
is he leverages
the health care system
to deliver the vaccination
okay now how does he do that here's what
happens tim you don't have kids yet but
when you have kids
you're going to be in the delivery room
kid's going to come out everyone's going
to be happy you're going to make sure
your wife is healthy the baby's healthy
and then the doctor is going to give you
a playbook
and the playbook is going to say we're
going to give these vaccinations today
you're going to bring your baby back in
six months it's going to get some a
checkup and some new vaccinations you're
going to bring your baby back in 12
months same thing 18 months same thing
the polio vaccination occurs during that
time period
any parent is always going to do well by
their kid
and make sure that they bring their kid
to the doctor checkups so it's not an
extra cost and you just naturally get it
so now you've overcome a really hard
problem about the situation here
now in chicago heights
the situation that i have is i hired 30
really good teachers if i want to scale
that thing up i need to hire 30 000 good
teachers and if i have to do that all in
the same input market say i have to do
that all around chicago heights i'm
screwed because i can't replicate the
quality of the original 30 good teachers
that's what i mean by properties of the
situation
the the fourth
vital sign is understand spillovers
or understand unintended consequences
in the jonah sulk case he's again got
that in spades because the polio
vaccination has these great
externalities once you get it you can't
give polio to somebody else
the fifth vital sign is understand the
supply side
and what that means is how much is it
going to cost
you to provide it
with medications
the the first feature of a medication is
most of our expenditures are up front
and then after you expend a bunch of
money on r d
you have what's called economies of
scale to actually make the vaccination
or make the pill
it's really really cheap
but
you also need to get into the people's
arms and that's where we're failing now
with the coveted vaccinations is
it costs a lot of money whereas in the
sulk case we've leveraged the health
care system so it's free because they're
going to come in anyway
and your baby just gets that vaccination
so that's that's kind of a running
example
that is really useful to know
because it checks all the boxes and as
you know it's skilled with great
brilliance
could you expand on the unintended side
effects the spillage maybe give
some examples of where things have gone
well or gone sideways
absolutely
so so one thing that
is
invisible
to the entrepreneur
or invisible to the firm is an
unintended consequence or what happens
after
i push my idea out there
now
one example of an unintended consequence
is what happened to us at uber
so
remember summer of 2017
we have this idea
that we are going to add
tipping
to the uber app
and in doing so we beta test it
what we find is we go to a market
and we allow five percent
of the drivers
to be able to receive tips
okay so what happens
they receive tips
they work more
and they make more money per hour
so it looks great when five percent of
the drivers have it
their wages go up
and their labor supply goes up
win win win
now when you roll tipping out to
every driver in that market
guess what happens
they see tipping they work more
but the market dynamics because everyone
has tipping
they undo
the tipping effect in fact more drivers
are working but they're driving around
with an empty car more often because so
many drivers are driving that the extra
tip effect is exactly offset
so that's an unattended consequence now
when we scaled it up drivers don't make
any more per hour with tipping they
exactly offset it and you didn't see
that when only five percent of the
drivers had tipping that's an example of
an unintended consequence that caused
all the good stuff of tipping
to go away now on the other side
sometimes you have good stuff think
about facebook
so facebook
if only five people in the world have
facebook
it's pretty useless
right it's not very valuable to me
but
if every one of my friends and every one
of their friends and every one of my
family members is on facebook there's
something called network externalities
that is more and more people get it
facebook becomes even more valuable
so you need to pinpoint does your idea
have these really cool network
externalities in this case or at scale
the good stuff becomes even better
these are things that i'm asking people
to measure and take account of makes me
think of
andy grove at intel and i think he used
to refer to it as paired incentives but
for any incentive
and i'm sure i'm getting the details
wrong here but he would he would ask
like what is the unintended side effect
what is the sort of perverse
behavior that you are
and i mean perverse as an undesirable uh
behavior that you are
also incentivizing that is not explicit
right yeah 100 and you should measure
both let me make this just purely
self-indulgent for a second so
let me lay out a challenge and you're
the perfect person to ask
so i have seen this and heard of this
across
ride sharing apps so i don't i don't
think it's unique to anyone but if dr
i've certainly run into this if drivers
are
penalized for canceling trips
but when they accept a trip they realize
oh wait that's a really short ride i
want an airport ride or something like
that
they will sometimes turn in the opposite
direction and just drive away to force
the rider to cancel
and then the rider gets penalized
and
i'm wondering how
presented with that issue how you'd
think about or how you have thought
about
mitigating it or or solving it when we
did a deep dive into
uber wages across men and women
what we found is something really
surprising
we found that men
earned about seven percent more per hour
than women
as an uber driver and that really
surprised us because
you know wages aren't negotiable
all men and women have the same rate
card and what a rate card means is
you're paid the same
time and distance
and women receive more in tips
than men receive so we were really
surprised and one reason why
is because men
strategically reject trips
and women accept all trips
so
a bad trip on lyft or uber
you're right one type of bad trip is i
have to drive a half hour to pick the
person up
and then i only have a five minute trip
right
one way to get around that problem is to
pay the driver
for time that they spend from when they
get the dispatch to when they pick
the customer up we we do that now at
lyft and that's an important reason
that you can lower rejection rates
now
there are still cases of cancellations
what we do is there's a fine for for
drivers in fact there's a fine for for
riders who do this too right there's a
cancellation fee of five dollars
and
i think using that mixture of
actually paying drivers to go pick
somebody up it and and having the
relevant fines right taking money away
clawing it back
is is kind of two instruments that we
find can be successful in lowering
exactly what you're saying because it's
irritating to sit out outside in the
cold i'm in chicago here and it's
freezing i sit out on the corner waiting
for
a driver and i see them going the wrong
way because they don't want to pick me
up
i'll feel a lot better if i know they're
being penalized versus if they just go
to a better trip right and you're right
the best trips are i'm gonna deadhead to
the airport and you also can't use your
app while they're
attempting to force you to cancel right
so that's right i remember staying with
a friend in malibu once and there's pch
and it's a mess right and if the drivers
are not paid for their transit time to
the pickup
then more often than not i mean you
would confirm the ride and then go back
to doing what you were doing knowing
that it would be there in 12 minutes and
then check 10 minutes later notice it's
cancelled so you can solve that by
paying them the driver by for the
transit time
what if it's a situation where it's like
downtown chicago or downtown austin or
wherever it is
and they're just looking for longer
trips so they start going in the
opposite direction how would you address
that
so they're not supposed to
know that
until you get in the car right yeah i
wonder why i mean it does happen to a
fair number of people i just wonder what
drivers usually do is they call you and
say by the way where are you going and
and then that's how a lot of times they
find out yeah so one way that we tackle
that is if we have under supply for
short trips
we end up giving incentive bonuses for
drivers
on
number of trips
so
for example you say you get the ride
bonus of 500 if you take 50 trips this
week the only way you can take 50 trips
is if you do a bunch of short trips so
there are ways to incentivize outside of
the rate card there are ways to
incentivize drivers for shorter long
trips and those are all at the disposal
and uber and lyft are constantly doing
these things yeah so i'm going to
provide some foreshadowing for a
question to come just so it can slow
bake sure so i want to talk about the
the four
secrets to high voltage after launch
scalable incentives marginal thinking
optimal quitting and building culture so
i'm gonna set that on just keep warm for
now
i i have to ask you though because you
in in a sense alluded to this but we
didn't get into the details
so you received your phd you went then
to sort of sell yourself on the academic
job market is 96
applied to 150 jobs usually the hit rate
is around 20 so one would expect around
30 interviews you got one so
there's that and then you were able to
sort of alchemize your career trajectory
and here you are right obviously in a
very different position and my question
is
what did people miss about you or what
did you miss or what mistake did you
make or what did you lack why did that
happen
yeah it's a really good question i've
been doing uh
the post-op for
over 25 years now
and
and i think it's sort of two parts one
part is
academia
is very
hierarchical and
the way the funnel works is that the top
schools you know harvard university of
chicago
princeton mit
etc
we put out about 20 to 30 students per
year
on this market with phds so we put out
25 students
this year with a phd from the university
of chicago
but we only hire back one or two
so the unwritten rule in academia
is
where you get your phd
the ranking of that school will be much
much higher
than you where you get your first job
and then where you get tenure
will be much much lower ranked than
where you get your first job
tough gig that's just sort of how the
funnel works
so when you start at the university of
wyoming
which is
i'm not sure what the ranking is but
it's certainly not in the top five
schools
if you follow that rule those top
schools they're not even going to open
my envelope
i didn't know this but when i applied to
the university of chicago
i'm quite confident that my application
envelope was never opened
because they saw the return address was
laramie wyoming
okay
so
i don't think it was anything that i did
wrong per se although it is true that
people were very very skeptical of my
field experiments in the early 90s
everyone said you're an idiot for doing
it you know we think you seem smart why
are you throwing your career away
if you want to do experiments you do
them in the lab what is this field
experiment stuff so you're right i
applied to 150 schools because i wanted
to be an academic i didn't want to be a
truck driver nothing wrong with truck
driver
but that was my outside option let's be
honest right if i don't get an academic
job i'm back in madison wisconsin
driving truck
so
i applied to 150 schools
and i still wear that today i got 149
people who told me you're not even
worthwhile talking to in an initial
interview and i saved every one of those
envelopes and said thanks but no thanks
and if i ever need motivation i can look
at that box
of envelopes that says go fly a kite
list
yeah when you get your yacht you can
laminate them and put them in the
floorboards
yeah yeah you know university of central
florida worked in it it ends up working
well i think too because what i see is
at the university of central florida i
could take chances
and i can continue to take
high variance plays and what i mean by
that is take risks
in in the research where if i started at
the university of chicago it might have
been harder because i might have wanted
to march to the same beat of every other
drummer around me
and and i think you you know university
of wyoming as a grad student university
of central florida
these sort of relieved the social
constraints
of having to be like everyone else and i
could just be me and i think in the end
it really helped a lot and that was kind
of the silver lining of my approach to
academia i think
i have to ask you and this may be a dead
end and we can cut it if it is this is
going to show you just how much i don't
know
which is not going to come as a surprise
to anyone listening
but you know when i when i think about
the
cold reception that you received based
on
the field studies and the directionality
of real world
experimentation people like you seem
smart this is stupid why are you being
stupid kind of reception
it reminds me of a documentary that i
recently watched as a nova documentary
on
fractals and benoit mandelbrot and i'm
wondering
because part of that documentary
discussed the the wide spectrum of
applications for fractals
lots of applications to physiology
cardiology i mean
extremely wide-ranging
is there any application for
fractal geometry or fractal mathematics
to economics is there any intersection
there i think there absolutely is
and i think as we move to
higher order computing
and as we move to
a higher order understanding that humans
have of how to apply
mathematical principles to real world
questions
i i think some of the big breakthroughs
will be in that area
and i think part of it is going to
be how do you solve
these problems and get a what's called a
closed form or an analytical solution
rather than have something be well
anything can happen
because when you deal with humans
you know the sciences are great because
we have laws
and we can talk about these laws because
they're physical constants they apply
everywhere that we at least understand
they can exist these laws apply
in economics when you talk about
predicting human behavior
we don't have quantitative laws
and and what we have are things that on
the one hand are kind of obvious like
our big law one of our big laws is the
law of demand
and basically what that says is when
price goes up quantity demanded goes
down well of course if price goes up you
buy less
and then what we don't even have a
physical or quantitative estimate
because
that's called in elasticity
but the elasticity depends on the good
and the circumstance
etc etc so we always have to measure it
i think when you start to add fractal
and in other aspects
it gives us a shot
at least to try to be more scientific
and i think going down those dimensions
can be useful i can't imagine an
application right now
but
that's the fun part about the
question right is that there are
possibilities
back when i started doing field
experiments everyone said
in part they're dumb
because i'm going to a baseball card
convention to gather data
and they said baseball card collectors
are weird
and the results won't generalize
and and that might be fine they might
generalize or they might not but what i
argued was the tool will generalize and
when we get to work with firms or
governments or
public education we can do large-scale
field experiments there just like hard
scientists and then we can say something
causal about the relationships that we
observe
yeah well and also if you're working i
mean this is obviously the reference
here is within the halls of academia but
if you're working private industry also
like
that weird group could actually
generalize to a pretty larger like a
much larger subset of the population
that is
like equally weird as a standard
deviation from whatever the hell normal
is
exactly you could have a great business
focusing on weirdos as long as there are
enough weirdos you sure can yeah so
let's come back to the
four secrets to high voltage after
launch and
i would love if we could explore these
through an example or an illustration
whether real or hypothetical
scalable incentives marginal thinking
optimal quitting and building culture
would you mind
expanding on those absolutely so the
back nine of the book
is
really meant for
the manager
or the decision maker who has scaled an
idea
so
a houston we have launch
and
after we've launched
what we have to think about is
how can we make sure
or at least give our idea
its best chance for high voltage
so
the back half of the book
really draws upon
my experiences in government in firms
to draw out
what what are the constant threads
that people make mistakes around
and the first chapter is
how to think about incentives that scale
and i think one of the big features
that we've learned in behavioral
economics
is that
using framing or loss aversion like the
clawback incentive which
is essentially give somebody an
incentive up front
and tell them you will take it away
unless they performed
that's called loss aversion or it is
built on the concept of loss aversion
and also
non-financial incentives i think a lot
of times we undervalue
both behavioral incentives and
incentives that don't involve cash
so things like
norms
things like peers like how much does my
coworker earn
that's interesting information or what
are their benefits or how many days off
do they get
or
if i perform in a certain way am i
adhering to the norms of my company
in many cases you know should i tip or
not in many cases
if we can leverage the insights from
behavioral economics and leverage what
we've learned about non-financial
incentives
in many ways these types of incentives
have the highest roi
because it's really cheap to give
non-financial incentives by definition
could you give an example
of a non-financial incentive that you've
seen work well
i think one example
that you can think about with
non-financial incentives is what we've
been doing with governments around the
world
so
think about the uk behavioral insights
team
or
in the dominican republic i've helped
the tax authorities
raise more money through getting people
to pay their taxes
in each of those cases we've used
messaging such as
70
of people have paid their taxes on time
why haven't you
that's a type of message that works it
gets people to pay their taxes
in the dominican republic we have a
paper titled the hundred million dollar
nudge
so the dominican republic has a real
problem with getting both individuals
and their firms to pay their taxes so
what we did is we went to them and said
here
here's a suite of behavioral
interventions that are all non-financial
things like
just a reminder that if you don't pay
your taxes you might have to serve jail
time
things like just to remind you if you
don't pay your taxes
we can make your name public and let the
world know that you haven't paid your
taxes
messaging like that we raised a hundred
million dollars more in tax receipts
which is like point two percent of gdp
in the dominican republic boring
uh maybe i don't think it's boring but a
tactical or a logistics question here
how is that messaging delivered was it
billboards
newsletters uh direct mail how was that
actually conveyed not boring at all
these are direct letters that the
dominican republic the irs sent so they
send a letter every year to people who
haven't paid their taxes all we did
is told them we think we can do better
than your letter
so we had them send the letter to a
group of people and then we augmented
their letter with a a sentence or two
yeah and
they always remind people to pay their
taxes but we used a little bit of
non-financial incentive
and we made bank for them
by the way the dr should should have a
uh
a statue soon of me in a park named
after me i hope but if there are any
people from the d r listening yeah arm
in arm with matt damon exactly exactly
so
so that's the first chapter in the
second half that the second chapter
is about
thinking about
making decisions on the margin
so
a lot of your listeners who have taken
economics 101
always hear this right make decisions on
the margin
and
what we do terribly in the classroom as
economics professors
is actually explain
what that means
and give an example of what it means
like what does it actually mean to think
on the margin
so
one example that i use in the book is to
think about what we do at lyft
so
i'm sitting in
a conference room at lyft and
the driver acquisition team comes in the
driver acquisition team is a team
that is responsible for recruiting new
drivers we need to keep putting new
drivers in the funnel because we want to
grow our supply what they present to me
is a slideshow
that has
here's how much money we spent on google
for ads to get new drivers
here's how much we spent on facebook for
ads to get new drivers and then they say
on average
we had to pay
500
per driver on facebook and on average we
had to pay 600
for drivers on google
okay
and then they say because of that
average
what we're going to do is we're going to
spend the next tranche on facebook ads
and i say whoa whoa whoa whoa
i don't care about the average
in the last half year
what i care about is how much did we
have to spend to get the last handful of
drivers the last 10 or 20 or 50
on google and facebook they say well let
us check
they go and then they come back and say
they say well on facebook it was 700 per
driver and on google it was 350.
then i'm like well wait a second
don't you think we should be moving
money then from facebook to google and
they're like yeah
but we we didn't think about like the
marginal driver like what was the last
driver and what would be the cost for
the next driver that's marginal thinking
and i i had this in the white house with
super fun cleanup and
we talked about how we should be
spending money across hazardous and
non-hazardous waste sites to clean them
up
averages in some cases
are very misleading
when you really should be thinking about
the last one and the next one rather
than a big average okay so that's
marginal thinking
now
the third one is is quitting
and
here this is this gets a little bit
personal
because
let's face it really the only reason why
i went to college i'm a first-gen kid i
went to college because i wanted to be a
golf bro
and i was offered a partial golf
scholarship to go to uw stevens point
university wisconsin at stevens point
and i went up there
this would have been the fall of 1987
and i started playing on the golf team
about midway through that fall season
we had a weekend off and i went back to
madison wisconsin and i happened upon a
a bunch of players one guy who's named
steve stricker
he's been on the pga tour for years one
is jerry kelly
these are guys i played against in high
school they were a few years in front of
me
steve went to university of illinois
jerry kelly went to hartford to play
play hockey and golf and then they both
made a ton of money later
but
it was really a hard lesson because i
watched them on the driving range
and i said wow these guys are really a
lot better than me i
didn't realize they were that much
better than me
but but you know
practicing confirmation bias i said but
i'm better than them around the greens
so you know when those scores come out
we're gonna i'm gonna show them you know
they went out in the morning i went out
in the afternoon and saw the scores and
they were just a lot better than me
and i ended up doing a bunch of data
crunching and i realized that everything
i was told as a kid because remember i
grew up in wisconsin and that's vince
lombardi country and vince lombardi is a
venerable coach of the green bay packers
when people win the super bowl
the trophy is called the lombardi trophy
so i was raised in the
shadows of vince lombardi who famously
said
winners never quit
and quitters never win
so and my parents taught me that time
and time again johnny you you have grit
you stick with it so it was really hard
for me to say
that dream is done i'm gonna have to
quit that dream i'm gonna fulfill the
golf scholarship and i went and played
and and i had a very successful college
golf career
but from that day on my dream was to
become an economist
and and i could i was still going to
invest in golf but it wasn't going to be
all in on golf it's going to be all in
on golf and all in on an econ
and learning about economics and how i
can use it as a trade when i quote grow
up
but but for me
what i see in the business world and in
government
is that people don't quit enough
they don't quit enough because they've
been taught not to quit
they also don't quit enough because they
don't understand or appreciate
the opportunity cost of time
you know when you think about the person
who
moves
to a different job
or they move to
a different apartment
nearly every time they're doing it
because something bad happened in the
workplace or something bad happened in
the apartment
that's all well and fine but you should
also be moving
when you get better opportunities
and you should always be looking at your
opportunity set
we don't do that we don't look at our
opportunities until our own lot in life
is soiled
and that's too late most of the time
because a lot of opportunities have come
and gone so that's called opportunity
cost because we don't realize that if
i'm working on this idea with all of my
might
that there's an idea out there that i
can't work on
and we tend to neglect
that opportunity cost of time
so
we we did this large scale experiment i
helped steve levitt design it and run it
that had people flip a coin
and if it comes up heads you know they
had a tough decision in life whether it
was a job a relationship an apartment
whatever
if it came up heads they need to change
if it comes up tails they don't
in our freakonomics experiment and what
you find is when you track them over
time
is that most of the people are much
happier that they made the change
so they didn't realize that there were
greener pastures out there until they
were sort of forced to do it
so that's the optimal quitting chapter
and the reason why again people don't
like to say the q word
so what i say is call an audible
right we always call an audible in
football we always pivot when people
pivot or call an audible in football
they're glorified
but when you say i'm quitting you're
chastised so i i think part of this is
just reframing
when you quit and we should understand
that it's pivoting or calling an audible
in your life
that's the optimal quitting chapter
how would you
give a pep talk to someone could be a
ceo it could be a student could be
anyone really
who's dealing with let's just call it
a data set
or just a life experience
that it that is not
black and white
and not to imply that your experience is
black and white but if you
if you go into the gym for basketball
practice and you're standing next to
michael jordan you're like okay
there's not much debate here at some
point like that is just a superior
player
and maybe i should choose a game where i
can be number one or number two or
something like that
there are many life circumstances or
business circumstances where it's kind
of a or appears to be like a 51 49 type
of situation and they're like well maybe
if we continue to split test and iterate
and
you know i've read all these success
stories could be survivorship bias but
nonetheless you know there are early
studies of like pivot pivot pivot and
then oh my god now you have twitter yeah
what do you say to those people or can
you think of a real world example where
it was it was tougher to kind of
determine whether to quit or not no
you're right you're right in in many
cases
we we sort of have these tweeners
where
you know the idea shows some
[Music]
signs you know and
and just enough to keep me going yeah
and the job the job shows some promise
just enough to kind of keep me going
so i i always say that you don't want to
quit
unless you know you have a good option
to go to
so
and that means that you should
periodically say once a month
look at your options
and and make sure
that the option is real
and also make sure that it
is along the lines of your comparative
advantage
so there not only needs to be something
that you can go to that's something
exists but also a comparative advantage
is what are you good at and what are you
passionate about doing
the long run
is filled with success
only if you can wake up every morning
and be passionate about something that
you're good at that's your comparative
advantage so i would say never move or
rotate
unless you know that where what you're
rotating to you're good at and you're
going to love and also that it's a real
option
otherwise there's no reason just
quitting to quit i i think that
there are a lot of tweener cases where
it could still work out
the problem is is that every time the
olympics comes when this is aired the
olympics will be on
and there will be a story every night
about the person who persevered
the person who had to go and work at the
grocery store and then they drove in the
forklift in the in the basement of
cheese factory
and lo and behold that person has become
a great bobsledder and then the mom is
on there saying i love johnny
and the dad is on there saying how we
knew johnny would never quit and these
are great feel-good stories
and that causes us
to want to persevere
but where is the story
for the billions of people
who went down the hole and they kept
going down the same hole every day
to a mine that had no
gold in it
where is that story written yeah i've
never read one so we don't realize that
there are billions of people
who have tried and tried and tried but
they keep hitting their head against the
same wall and they never succeeded
that's lost opportunity right there
yeah it's uh
it's a harder uh story to use on the
cover to sell magazines
yeah nobody wants to buy that story
because that's the story of many
people's lives
nobody wants to read about their own
life
right
building culture let's touch on that the
culture chapter was really fun to write
because it allowed me
to
sort of reflect on what happened at uber
and also reflect on
the research that i've been engaged in
for over 20 years
which is along the questions of
you know why do women get paid less than
men in doing the same job
why do people discriminate against one
another in markets you know what are the
underpinnings for that discrimination
and how can we think about diversity and
inclusiveness in a way
that a firm really wants to do it and
they're doing it for the bottom line
not just to get moral cookies because in
the end we need we want both we want
both
morality to tug at it but we also want
to make sure the firm is doing what
right by their shareholders because
that's what a lot of times people are
going to make decisions around
so
the chapter in a way begins
in brazil we did some work
amongst brazilian fishermen in two very
distinct communities
one community
had fishermen who had to fish in teams
and in those teams they had to go out in
the boat
the ocean's very rocky they all go out
together
they bring back their catch and they all
share it and in those villages are also
built on community
when it's outside of the workplace too
so just like this brilliant utopia of
everyone cooperating and getting along
now
inland
there's a similar village except those
fishermen go to a lake
and they all work in a solo way soloists
and what happens there is when they get
to the community
they also act in a soloist form
so what's kind of cool
is that you observe there that the
workplace
bleeds over to society
and in the one society you have a lot
more of the great public goods being
provided and the other society it looks
more selfish so we did a bunch of
experiments in these two societies and
lo and behold we find that what happens
in the workplace really spills over to
the community
so
bringing all that together
what i say in the culture chapter is
is a firm or isn't an
organization
we should want to build our own kabucho
that that's the society that is built on
community spirit
and we should do that from the very
beginning
and very subtle things like
letting people know
that wages are negotiable
in our job advertisements you know that
seems kind of innocuous if you say wages
are negotiable well what does that do
what it does is something interesting it
gives women
sort of the license to negotiate because
what we find in our data
is when you say in your job ad that
wages are negotiable
women will negotiate as much as men
and they will end up with similar wages
but if you leave that sentence out
women will not negotiate at all really
and then they start with lower wages
so right away just your job
advertisement it leads to a pool of
applicants that can differ but also the
wages might differ
and if you want to scale a culture of
equality and and and you're paid your
marginal product and we're not going to
let subtle things happen that lead to
very different wage profiles we can do
that from our very beginning of our firm
so the idea is there are a lot of little
nuggets in that chapter about how you
can build your kabucho
and those are the tips in chap in the
chapter on build your own culture i
don't know if this is going to tie in
culture it certainly doesn't have to but
i am looking at some of your favorite
things and i see stubhub could you
please explain why stubhub is
on your favorites list oh wow one of my
favorite apps is indeed stubhub
so stubhub is great because it's the
ultimate
market
for seats to events
and i don't i can wait till the last
minute i can do a model about what
prices do i've bought super bowl tickets
on stubhub the other night i went to the
bulls game i sat courtside at the bulls
game wait wait till the end there are a
few courtside seats for 350 each
my wife gets to hug benny the bull
i don't have to make plans till the very
end it's the ultimate market that's
based on supply and demand and then
there's a little bit of behavioral
economics in there because i've sold on
stub hub too
and it's kind of neat because i have to
try to figure out how should i price
and if my tickets aren't selling how
should i depreciate my prices if i
really don't want to go to this event so
it's a economist playground here stubhub
is but plus
it's great in many cases for the
customer but also for the seller
this is i don't like stubhub's fees that
much but uh but nevertheless they're
taking their uh
their bite from the apple as well and
i'm still getting some surplus so i love
stubhub
you know i was just thinking
having had a number of podcasts now
interviewing people about web 3. it's a
somewhat controversial term but let's
just
let's just make it more specific
nft marketplaces where all of the
transactions
are recorded and can be reviewed on the
blockchain i would imagine
that that would provide
an
incredible playing field for behavioral
economists who have
the ability to crunch data like data
scientists i would imagine you could
probably pull all sorts of fascinating
behaviors also see bad behaviors i'm
sure people are doing wash trading and
things like that but
because it is all
preserved and there's this
self-similarity in the blockchain in the
sense you have all these nodes that have
in effect copies of these ledgers
you could really do some
fascinating digging i would have to
imagine but that's just just me no
you're right 100 and just thinking about
fintech in general
we've
we've thought hard about
how we can be players there when i say
we i mean my team and we have a few
irons in the fire now question for you
is this your university team or is this
like a private uh
kind of seal team six
for-profit team that you've assembled
uh a combo combo
combo platter because what we have is we
we have great phd students here who want
to work on cutting edge
data science
and and why wouldn't i look there
right and and not only because
there's a wealth of data but also
because there are a lot of big juicy
apples that are hanging pretty low
yeah and it's going to be really
important not only for
consumers but also for regulators
regulators are thinking very hard now oh
yes they are about what they should be
doing
and in many cases they're flying blind
and they're flying blind because people
have not taken seriously a ton of what
are the learnings
from the data and and what are the
social costs
or or potential
you know back in the day in the in the
2008 financial crisis we learned a lot
from that and a lot about the system
and some of the weak points remember a
lot of this this comes back to the
weakest link problem
a lot of these examples are
you're as weak as your weakest point and
if that implodes you're done
and it's it's really trying to
understand questions around that so
we're dabbling a bit tim and uh fintech
but
nothing to talk about just yet
well
i'll take that as a teaser i look
forward i look forward to when you can
discuss more publicly the next book the
next book so speaking speaking of books
i do want to ask you about a specific
book and i will admit right up front
that i'm embarrassed i haven't read this
book
and that is wealth of nations by adam
smith which i know you're a fan of
absolutely part of the reason i haven't
read this book is
the same reason that i had some
misgivings about this nova documentary i
watched about mandelbrot and fractals
because the documentary was made
more than 10 years ago
and i know a lot has happened in the
intervening 10 years and i don't know
what has been disproven or what has been
updated what has been amended so my
question is
if one were to read wealth of nations by
adam smith
what caveats
uh or preface would you provide so that
they are not misled
i don't say misled so that they
they read it as informed
and contemporary as a way as possible
yeah i would probably say don't read the
original so my advice is don't read it
and the reason why is because a it's
painstakingly written
so
smith had
this feature that a lot of writers back
then
had to make a point
that can be made in a paragraph
ends up being 25 pages
of words that you have to look up what a
lot of them mean
but the true beauty is exactly as you
pointed out for an economist the true
beauty is
i sort of know
how the profession has evolved and how
economic thinking has evolved
and for me the wealth of nations is so
beautiful because it's set off
he's a father of economics and it's set
off his level of thinking
must have been the deepest of any
philosopher i've ever read
and and i can appreciate the beauty
because i know a lot about economics and
where it's gone since then like he he
talks about specialization as an example
a specialization in the pin factory and
he goes through this long and tortuous
and arduous explanation
of the pin factor i'm like
adam just get through it this is crazy
so so i can i can jump and see the
beauty about what was known but to me
the beauty is a lot of that was not
known and he had these gems
so i think it would be incredibly
difficult
for a person who is not well versed in
economics to read adam smith because it
would be a ton of head scratching like i
think he's trying to get at this issue
but i don't know it's kind of that one
and maybe i should just read the theory
of moral sentiments so i think for the
person who
is not a an astute an expert reader
i would say go to the
moral sentiments because they're there
you got kind of the
the behavioralists at work adam smith is
one of the early behavioral
economists and he talks about the moral
hector on one shoulder etc etc and you
see a lot of the underpinnings of
behavioral economics a lot of the
underpinnings of behavioral economics
are common sense
and then you can kind of see wow he had
that idea back then
it took him a long time to say it but
nevertheless right he's verbose in the
in the theory as well
but but nevertheless i would probably
say the reader would direct there and
then after you take several econ classes
then go to the wealth of nations
right so you're not reading an ancient
medical textbook and coming up with
phrenology is the cutting-edge treatment
or diagnostic tool
you know another approach that i might
take
is to read
as a starting point the wikipedia entry
on adam smith and the wikipedia entry
and wealth of nations because there will
be
footnotes and references and also
mentions of different controversies or
updates or factual inaccuracies or
whatever it might be
so i might start with that and then jump
to moral sentiments
well john this has been so much fun
people can certainly learn more about
the latest book at
thevoltageeffect.com that is effect with
an e e f f e c t
voltage effect
subtitle how to make good ideas great
and great ideas scale you're an
excellent teacher i i have really
enjoyed this conversation and you're
very very good at weaving
together examples and illustrations with
principles which i just
i just think is so critical if you want
anything to stick which makes me all the
more interested in studying what you did
with this preschool so another
conversation for another time we didn't
even get to dig into the soccer team
that you have at home
there's eight kids so we'll go further
with that maybe in another conversation
but is there
anything else that you would like to say
any closing comments requests of the
audience anything at all that you'd like
to add before we we close up for this
first conversation
i just want to say thanks tim for having
me the book does cover you know my work
with the chicago white sox i i built a
draft model for them and i called it
moneyball
infinity because it takes a moneyball
idea and the data science idea
to a new level you know i i have data
all the way back to
kids who are seven and eight years old
so i know bryce harper stats when he was
eight and i scraped a bunch of data and
uh built a model for the white sox and
and i bring that up because
economics is life
and life is economics and with a little
bit of data
and just an economics 101 understanding
you can really go a long way to change
the world and make it a better place you
know from the white sox to the white
house
to uber and lyft to the academy
the type of thinking
not only around scaling
and how to scale ideas but also just
very simple economic principles
will absolutely make your life and your
family's life a lot better
well i am very excited
to
not just dig into the new book but dig
into just about everything that you've
done it's been so fun to prepare for
this conversation
and
i really appreciate you taking so much
time
and
again probably at some point we'll see
if it happens but do a round two just to
talk about how
in the hell you get all this done i mean
i'm looking at the list of your projects
it goes on for pages and pages of pages
didn't even get to talk about vernon
smith and gary becker another time
[Music]
prospect theory although we i think we
touched on a good portion of that there
is so much here
so i look forward to
the book and learning more from you
virtually maybe maybe directly
and really appreciate you uh sharing
your knowledge and learnings and
successes and failures with us in this
in this conversation so thank you very
very much
and for everybody listening we will have
links to
everything we've discussed in the show
notes as per usual at tim.log slash
podcast
and
until next time thank you so much for
tuning in
you